Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier, and welcome back to Subnautica: Below Zero.
Now, I am not going to be as big of
a bitch baby as I was in the last one.
But what I am going to do is I am going to go find some way to start building stuff
Now, I know that the story is going to unfold and all that stuff,
and people are going to talk to me
and I sent them my stool sample up to the space station n' whatever.
But I need to figure out how to get
the builder tool.
Because without that I'm not actually going to be able to do any base building
which is like a big part of this game.
And if there is no base-building
then that just seems weird and I don't believe in that at all.
But since I don't believe in that I'm actually not going to let that get me down
And I'm just gonna go out and about and see what happens
Is this dead? No, that's good. Okay.
So let's go out.
It's beautiful, as always.
It's frickin' gorgeous and that's nice and all--
But at the same time,
I don't like it.
Also, I updated some stuff in my recording, uh, equipment finally.
I am the kinda person that doesn't update unless I have to.
Uh, but I finally updated
and uh things should run a lot smoother than they have in the past.
Oh, that is buttery smooth.
I'm not getting a single stutter anymore!
Aw, this is a dream!
Oh hey, hey dude!
Hey dude! Hey dude, how you doin'?
Hey how you doin' dude?
Okay, so I don't know exactly where I'm going-
'weowh', that was a little fast.
So I don't know exactly where I'm going, but,
I'm just kinda getting a lay of the land, because,
I know--I'm kinda near--what, no I'm not? Where am I?
Wait, where am I?
Woah woah what was that?
I saw something under there.
What's that?
Is that just not supposed to be there?
I think that might be a bug or something.
Oh well. Woah.
Hey! Hey dudes, what are you doing out here?
Eugh
Woah, that looks unfinished.
I think I'm reaching the relative outskirts of where the game
is and is not finished.
Hey dudes, can I steal your air?
Which is a weird thing that I can do to you guys.
I don't know how I sucked that outta you, but,
I don't think either of us are happy about it.
Sploosh.
Woah.
Maxim: Goodall, this bio sample you sent us,
it bears no resemblance to your bio metrics.
Maxim: And the alien facility? It spoke your name?
Okay, well, that- that guy
I love that character.
Whoever is the voice actor for that guy,
perfect.
No better.
The dialogue didn't match at all, I don't care, that was awesome. Well done.
We are completely lost.
I've no idea where I am. Hey can I get some o2?
Thank you.
Hello, can I have you?
Yoink.
Now, a lot of this game is going to be unfinished.
But, until I have a more specific set of directions to follow,
my best- hueyy
Ohhh, you nibbled that right out from under me.
Congratulations, you scared me.
Way to go.
Yeah, so, in- in the meantime, until I have a more specific direction to go--
I'm sending down a builder- a builder tool!
That's exactly what I was looking for!
If I had known that I would've stayed in the safety of my own pod!
I didn't know that you were going to be delivering it to me hand personally.
You sending down like an air drop? Should I-- sure wish I could see with my eyes.
That'd be nice. Um, hello?
Oh-kay, ooh!
Hey! That's--
on the ice- no. Wait, no.
No, I was--no, don't. You send it down directly where I was but I'm not over there. No!
NooOooO!
Oh, it's okay. Ohh, there's an opening here. Oh, well then-
Oh! Then, convenient! Okay, I didn't- I had no foreknowledge of anything coming down here,
so the fact that it dropped exactly where I was is literally just a coincidence.
I swear to you.
All right, what do we got? Euh-yes
Yes!
Yeess!
I can feel safe, I can feel kinda safe cuz' I got a builder tool.
And that's pretty good!
And so with a builder tool, I'm able to build stuff.
If you didn't know about builder tools,
that's stuff you can build with. Okay, this is good.
Everything's looking up!
Everything's looking good!
I know there's nothing scary down here.
See, once- it just takes me a little time, I get comfortable-
Oh.
Ohh, okay.
Thank you? I think?
All right, so, if I am not stupid-
I would take my shit from in here, my titanium-
Brrrr, myyyy--silver? My lube, my silicone rubber-
Uh, some
copper,
uh, quartz for glass,
and not that much quartz
and one more 'titunium',
and maybe get rid of the salt.
And I'll take that with me, maybe one less of that.
Maybe one more 'titunium', and I'll cook up this artic peeper,
and eat it.
And then I'll be good to go.
Right? That sounds good
Can I mention for a second..like this is so cool.
Like as much as it terrifies me..
It also is very captivating.
Like the ocean an-and
This isn't even the real ocean, but this ocean in of itself
is so in depth,
s-so broad, and the work
that they've put into it already it really does
build on the subnautica wha-
that was on there before. Like in the original
like the wonder of it, the
open spaces of it. The alien nature
of everything in this place. The way
it just doesn't make any sense at all.
and yet, it's all there and it's
crazy when you really think about it. And
it's so cool that they've managed to
deliver this experience again. And it's not done, it's gonna be years before
it's done. Probably another two years
of slow updates, but
it'll get done. And they'll do it and
that's like a fascinating- ughh..
that's a fascinating thing to see
and I'm just like..
I'm really blown away by the level of a detail
or the attention to detail that they put
into these games. I just- woah..
I think it's cool. Hello...
huhah..well well well well
I don't even need to make a home
oh..shit. Alright
how about that- woah..
okay. Can I get in here?
No? Can I get in here at all?
No? Is there an entrance..?
I thought that was an entrance over there, but apparently not.
Lemme see if I can build one
Umm...hatch. Here we go...no?
OH is this like
place holder
bullshit and it doesn't actually
work? Nah..
I think this would- yea
Ohooo
Oh..it's a dead. Ohh what's that?
Can I have that? Can I has that?
Hello?
Ah..that's a problem, okay.
But I see a-
woo..okay
Wow.. I'm gonna die
I better hurry, I just gotta
Woah..straight through a window then.
Alright..Well this is bizarre. Why is this
down here, in the middle of nowhere?
You've would of think we've known about this or someone would of have
said something about this.
I mean like it's not like it the same situation as before.
I guess I should understand that
this has now been thoroughly explored
Oh